will you please state your name  yes it's amber laura hurd and what is  your address  i live in yucca valley california  and how old are you amber  i am 36 i just celebrated  okay and do you have a daughter  i do uh she also celebrated her birthday  recently she's won  okay  and what is your profession  i am an actor uh mostly  okay  now why are you here  i am here because my ex-husband is suing  me  for an op-ed i wrote  and how do you feel about that  i  um  i  struggle to have the words  i struggle to find the words to describe  how  painful this is  this is horrible  for me to sit here  for  weeks and  relive everything  um  here  people that i  knew um  some well some not  my ex-husband with whom i shared a life  um  speak um  about our lives in the way that they  have  um  this has been one of this is the most  painful and difficult thing i've ever  gone through  for sure